.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Howie Morenz,
the Babe Ruth of hockey.
- En 1931, au tout nouveau Maple
Leaf Gardens, une foule record
de plus de 15 000 spectateurs
assistent à un match entre
les deux équipes canadiennes
les plus célèbres.
- Two great teams battling it
out for supremacy.
- Une rivalité légendaire
est née.
- This is the playoff!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Toronto et Montréal se livrent
des batailles mémorables.
- The fans are in a frenzy.
Every game of séries
has gone into overtime.
- En 1951, les Maple Leafs
battent les Canadiens
en finale, mais Montréal
prépare sa revanche.
- Three seconds to go,
into the corner, here
he comes, the game is over.
Canadiens win the Stanley Cup!
- C'est contre les Maple Leafs
que les Glorieux remportent
leurs 4e et 5e coupes Stanley
d'affilée, en 1959 et 60.
Et c'est très valorisant de
savourer la victoire devant
l'ennemi juré de Toronto.
TOE BLAKE, entraîneur-chef,
Canadiens de Montréal
- J'ai jamais été si content
de toute ma vie pour avoir
gagné ce championnat.
- Les confrontations Toronto-
Montréal ont toujours la cote.
Des événements historiques
s'y produisent.
- Et pour la première fois
dans l'histoire, un gardien
de but porte un masque
en séries éliminatoires.
- Outre Jacques Plante,
Maurice Richard
s'illustre aussi.
- Maurice is right in front
and he scores!
(cris de la foule)
- Le Rocket a déjà inscrit
cinq buts lors d'un match
éliminatoire contre Toronto.
Quand aux Leafs, c'est contre
le CH qu'ils ont gagné la Coupe
Stanley pour la dernière fois,
en 1967.
- The Toronto Maple Leafs
have won the Stanley Cup!
- Le Tricolore détient
un mince avantage de 8 victoires
en 15 séries contre Toronto,
mais les deux derniers
affrontements se sont
soldés par des balayages.
- Et le but!
(cris de la foule)
- Eh bien, voilà...
le moment dramatique!
Les Leafs sont terrassés;
les Canadiens jubilent.
- Des victoires qui
remontent à 1978 et 79.
- Larry Robinson, le héros!
(cris de la foule)
- Un duel Toronto-Montréal qui
avait pris fin dans le désordre.
Larry Robinson, forcé de calmer
Tiger Williams, qui voulait
s'en prendre à l'officiel qui
l'avait puni en prolongation.
Il a fallu attendre 42 ans pour
assister au prochain épisode.
Ici Jean-François Poirier,
Radio-Canada, M